foreign
let's go to Eric in Wichita Kansas
what's up Eric
hey Dr John thank you so much for taking
my call you got me hey thanks for
calling and uh
you got to hear how the sausage is made
man that's pretty good I did thanks for
all you do and my wife and I are huge
fans and we listened to you for a long
time and uh
bricks and paintings are talked about
frequently in our house so oh man that's
so great dude that's awesome man yeah so
what's up brother how can I help
okay so I'm gonna give you a little just
a quick snippet of a background and I'll
ask a question but uh there's a big
disagreement that what my wife and I
have and it stems from our 25 year old
daughter is in a relationship she's now
married to a convicted child molester's
registered sex offender
whoa so she is married
she is married now yes okay
and so the question is what should be
our role as Christians what should be
our role in our attitudes toward him
and I think and I've taken the the road
of I want nothing to do with him I don't
want him in my house I don't think he's
safe and my wife has a huge heart and
she wants to make everyone happy and she
thinks that we should forgive him and
allow him to be a part of our lives and
just be cautious
okay
um
what what was the what was the offense
um
lewd misconduct of a 14 year old girl
so he was 20. he hooked up with a 14
year old didn't have sex with her but
right okay and of course he says he's
innocent of course but he but he pled
guilty okay that I mean sometimes uh
sometimes that's the easiest way out and
sometimes people get bad legal advice
and so that doesn't automatically mean
that they're guilty but
um yes I've very met very few people on
the sex offender registry list that
aren't completely innocent bro I didn't
do anything
um and I've also had some folks in my
life
um a couple former students that ended
up on that list I think wholly unjustly
and so
um that's why the the that question is
important what happened
how old is he now
he's
27. okay did he go to jail
yes okay how long is he in jail
I think he was in jail for two years two
years okay and what is his
um what's his life look like now
that's that's the thing uh it's horrible
I mean it's
um
she met him okay I'll just give a little
more background now if you don't mind
but she met him five or six years ago
and brought him into our lives uh she
had had left our home and
um gone to college and had some
roommates and then
decided to move in with him and his
family
and that's not as a boyfriend but just
brought him around we accepted him I
never did like him to be honest with you
uh it's just creepy and he's a big
talker
um and figured out very quickly that he
can't tell the truth
and so I because my daughter liked him
my golden eyes and I just tried to play
nice and just put up with him
and then
um he and through the first couple years
he interacted with our extended families
through graduations birthday parties
holidays funerals he would show up and
and that's the part that's so hard for
me to take now
um and even
her my daughter my I have a couple of
boys too and and uh during that time
they had people here at our house all
the time this was the place where the
high school was hung out and so there
was girls here all the time when he was
here and we didn't know this at first
about is that that's a violation of his
parole huh
well that's what we're finding out
exactly so he had a parole officer for a
long time that did nothing and he just
could do whatever he wanted and now just
a couple I think it was last year he got
a new parole officer and really cracked
down on him and we're finding out what
all the things he can't do
and uh but he just and we didn't like I
said we didn't know it at the time and
when about four years ago
um they had a baby
and soon after the baby was born is
where I just did a Google search okay
and I found out okay and I confronted
them and
of course he didn't do it and all this
and that and
and I was just furious because I was
just thinking back of all the times that
we had put people we care about
in the same room as this absolutely yeah
person yeah yeah
and then right after the baby was born
then he took off and took him away from
us
and retaliation of us finding out in my
reaction
um and we didn't see I mean we'd see him
but whenever we wanted to see him we
couldn't and he just played this little
manipulative game with us and uh
took her to Vegas and
basically told her if you don't marry me
then
I will take your son and you'll never
see him again
so she married him and told us about two
months later and she still she she never
refers to herself as his wife or
anything she doesn't
um so here's a here's a couple here's a
couple things hold on here's a couple
things
I ramble so no no no hey trust me if
you've listened to my show I rambled bad
so good to be another Rambler man um
there's a couple of false dichotomies
going on here that we can just bust
right through them okay
you can call his parole officer and say
for the last two years four years five
years he's interacted with numerous
teenagers and children
because he deceived us
as a clear violation of his parole you
can report him
number two your daughter
can if she is trapped
um if she's being
yeah if she's being held against her
will relationally she can go get an
attorney and say my husband is a
um on the sex offender registry he is
continually violated his parole being
around young kids
he threatened me to steal my child and I
tearfully and fearfully
um got married to him because I don't
lose my kid now I'm clear-minded I'm
sober thought and thought and I need out
of this thing but I don't want to lose
my baby
right well she won't do that she won't
I'm telling you she won't lose her baby
is what I'm saying yeah right no we
we've told her that and uh there's
there's more to the story so she's
adopted we got her two and a half years
old
she's had a troubled troubled life yeah
but a good life we had her in counseling
we had her in therapy sure y'all did
what you could Because You Loved Her
yeah and she's bipolar and
um she's but she's made bad choices and
we've had
when we get her by herself and have
conversations it's the I know I know I
know I know we can talk sense to her but
the minute she goes back then yeah she
is just sucked back into it and she left
him one time yeah and uh but then three
days later went back all right so here's
um man I think I'm gonna make everybody
mad with my answer here
and I reserve the right to come back in
a couple episodes and change my mind
because this is one I seen to Think
Through
um okay
you're you're making two choices here
number one am I going to be in a
relationship with this guy
and number two am I going to be in
relationship with my daughter and my
grandson
right those are two different two
different
um questions you're going to be
answering but you're gonna be answering
with the same decision
okay okay
so in many ways you're playing a long
game here for the heart and soul and
mind of your daughter and your grandkid
because this relationship doesn't last
it ends we all know this
right right and so we're playing a long
game here the second is
man in this is hard I got a six-year-old
daughter okay I got 12 year old son oh
yeah
um
but I have to say I'm a part of a
society
that has rules and boundaries
and penalties
and when you
have paid your penance
I'm not holding up mine to the bargain
if you return to society as we all
agreed and I continue to
not allow a shred of redemption in your
life
that doesn't mean I'm going to put my
hand back in the bag and get bitten by
rattlesnake again
it does mean that for me
I err on the side of redemption I also
could give two craps about the words
that come out of your mouth I Gotta See
actions
and so I'm less concerned
that he went to jail for X number of
years for what he did he got out he paid
his penalty
I'm way more concerned that he instantly
violated parole
because on top of being somebody who
hooked up with a 14 year old he is
somebody of no character
who and more importantly perhaps he has
no he has no regard for the law
because
I mean just think about it you just get
out of jail
and they tell you if you go within 200
feet of somebody under the age of 18 you
violate your parole you go back and you
go longer
and he didn't care enough to leave the I
would have left that house running and
screaming
when when one of my little when my
girlfriend's little brother showed up
with some of his friends you know what I
mean
yeah he didn't care
no and he's there's just so many red
flags that
so here here's here's what I would do if
I was you okay and this is me just off
the top of my head here
I would invite him out to a very direct
conversation with just us two
and say here's the deal
you've lied to me since the day I met
you
've not been a person of integrity
you're on the sex offender registry list
and you've got every story in the book
but fine
you're also married to my daughter and
you're the father of my grandson
I'm willing to give you access to me in
return but in return for the privilege
of that access to my family
is Crystal Clear honesty from this
second forward
and
um you're gonna you're gonna have
breakfast with me once a week
you're gonna check in with me
and if you choose does that make sense
so here's what you're doing you were
leaning into that relationship but he's
got to bring it
and let them know if you choose to not
come to breakfast with me if you choose
to lie one time to me my wife my
daughter
you are choosing to opt out of our life
and I know you've broken the law up
a hundred times that you got out of jail
I will do everything I can to send you
back to Joe
and get you out of my family's life
everything
but I'm also willing to open up my front
door to you
if you if you walk the walk walk the
walk
I and here's my thinking on that
I know the recidivism rates for people
who are Russia sex offenders who don't
get help people who do get help uh oh it
just depends that's a whole other
conversation
um but who don't get help it's so high
he's going to do something stupid again
and hurt somebody but he's been let out
right
that's right he's out
um it might be that this 14 year old
looked 18 and he was what 20.
and he's a young squirrely looking 18
year old it looked like like a young
squirrely 18 year old and he happened to
be 20. like
I understand whatever right I mean
whatever here we are
um I'm way more concerned at his
Cavalier and his his
your daughter's story that's there's his
brother's in jail now for doing the same
type of thing to a 10 year old
and his his dad has molested his sister
and never got caught and so and to the
point where he says to my wife don't
come around when my dad's around because
it's not safe
but it's the environment they choose to
live in
but uh so maybe that maybe the harder
conversation is between you and your
daughter
okay
um
I appreciate the idea though I think
because since I found out I've
he's scared to death at me so if I'm
around he leaves if like if he drops off
the ground
baby or whatever but uh I mean you
probably haven't made it super welcoming
right I wouldn't have no right
absolutely not yeah no I want him to be
uncomfortable there you go
um and so maybe the
man
yeah I think I think the relationship
with the daughter I think you hit she
wrote me a letter about a year ago okay
and I just pulled that letter out in the
last couple days and
she thanked me for everything that I
made bad choices but you still love me
and
um actually
I need to read that letter once a month
yeah you do you do you do because you
beat yourself up over the situation now
you're blaming yourself okay don't do
that oh yeah you guys worked your butts
off
okay you'll love that girl with
everything you had
yes and it might be a season
a harrowing nightmare season
where you call your daughter and you
take her to breakfast and you say
foreign
's not safe
I can't stand by and watch my grandkid
my baby girl
be in this situation and I also know the
limits of what I can do as an adult
you're a grown-up you can do what you're
going to do
great and so I am choosing
to opt out of our relationship for this
season because you've chosen him over us
and
good to you you leaved and cleaved
I just can't participate in this
and
I'll always love you I will not always
love your decisions those aren't
mutually exclusive
no you're right but at some point I have
to for me and my family I gotta draw a
line this guy can't come to our house
you can't I can't no but I could could
we just allow her to come and bring
bring the kiddo
and just knowing that he's not welcome
or is that just I mean you can but
you're putting your daughter in a
position to choose between her husband
and her family
yeah and that's what she's done the last
couple years yeah it's been four years
actually that's choosing to create an
environment where you know your daughter
can't win
that's true right she I mean that's what
it is it's what you're doing there is
you're making her the
she becomes the fulcrum of that leverage
you want what you want because you want
to see that kid and you want to hug your
daughter
but you do it at the expense of her
husband
and so she's got to choose to exit out
of her relationship moment children with
her husband to enter into a relationship
with Mom and Dad and then she's gotta
exit out of that one to get back in I
mean that's just just go run and be free
if you're choosing him go run and be
free but choosing him means you're
you're choosing to opt out of our
relationship and it breaks our heart
because we love you so deeply
this one's tough man thanks for letting
me think through this one out loud I do
think
um faced in a similar situation I would
take him out just man-to-man
and say here is how this is going to go
and your margin for error is zero
I better not see a spit on the sidewalk
I better not even get a whiff
of you being dishonest you will tell the
truth and you may not even know what
telling the truth looks like because
your debts is a scumbag and your
brothers are scumbags and you grew up in
the house of
evil and dysfunction
and molestation
in disgust
I'll model for you what it looks like
I'll give you a shot
but because you've lied so much
previously your your margin of error is
zero
but I'll be that man you didn't have
and then it's Checkmate brother your
move
foreign
conversation with my daughter
let me know that um conversation with
him goes I'd love to know how that
breakfast or lunch turns out and it may
be good Eric for you to write down what
you want to say to him
that way it doesn't get emotional it
doesn't get fired up and when he tries
to protest you can say he hadn't seem to
read you this letter let's start there
that's a heartbreaker my brother